Next, we want to provide a few tips and tricks for your rendering inside of Unreal Engine 5,
so that it helps give you some efficiencies in your workflow.
So kicking off with Lumen here, Lumen currently doesn't fully support mirror reflections.
So it's limited, but on the roadmap, so at the time of viewing,
you can just check the support of Lumen on the reflections here.
And Lumen does not support static lights either.
So you're in a, whereas if you are using baked lighting,
you could change your light modes to static, stationary, movable.
Lumen just handles the same light type for all.
So disabling allow static lighting can help with some overhead
and make sure your Lumen AO process is working with no visual hindrances.
Lumen supports material ambient occlusion, ideal for characters,
cheaper than a bent normal for characters.
So with Lumen, temporal super resolution, which is TSR,
may blur out the world position offset effect.
To remedy that, you can go to your project settings,
go down to the render tab, into optimizations, velocity pass,
and switch to right during base pass.
And making foliage movable in the foliage editor can also correct the blurring caused
by the world position offset, which is the wind effect.
And then there's just an image to show you about the velocity pass option
that you'd change there.
With path tracer, we're talking about denoising.
So even with high sample counts, path tracer will always have a bit of residual noise
in the rendered frame.
So denoising option in the post-processing volume settings will make use of
Intel's open image denoise library to remove noise from the last sample.
So the denoiser runs on the CPU and is not currently designed for interactive denoising.
So rather to help improve the quality of long running frames,
it does not currently guarantee temporal consistency.
And relatively high samples per pixel are required for stable output.
So temporal stability can also be improved by increasing the temporal sample count
in the anti-aliasing settings in the movie render queue.
And then also animated items may still have flickering shadows.
So setting spatial and temporal sampling counts to 10 can help.
So path tracer is still evolving, many changes per engine version.
So it's always useful checking the path tracer documentation,
which we've got in a slide in a second for you to check the latest on path tracer.
Here are a few common console variables that you may use for when you approach ray tracing.
We've got some meta human specific CVAR settings here in orange,
which you may want to tweak, but you can also find a list of these online.
But again, the render queue supports console variables.
So if you want to set any of these when you're outputting,
and if you file types, you can set these on the project.
And then you've also got some sky and atmosphere systems that you can tweak here.
So worth digging into all of these, playing around,
seeing what you can set and really define the look and feel of what your project requires.
The GPU timeouts, so the TDR delay settings,
type regedit into the Windows search bar to navigate to this category,
select the TDR delay from the list, right click modify,
and you can select the base's decimal.
So change the value data to 1690 or 120, and then hit OK.
And if the TDR delay doesn't exist in the category list,
move your pointer to the open folder, right click,
select new select D word, which is 32 bit value from the options menu,
and then select the base's decimal.
Hit the value data to 1690 or 120 again, and then hit OK.
So all of the documentation that you need for any of these tips and tricks
can be found on the resources below.
And then just for the credits of the slides again, this was Kevin and Sean.
We got further documentation on some sequence of workflows,
and then also some additional documentation on the movie render queue.